in the multiverse bending spider-man no
way home one spider-man variant gets his
long-awaited redemption but does the
other one lose the love of his life
i know you predicted i disappoint you
bingo
fans blood went cold the minute toby
maguire's peter said the two most
dreaded words someone can say regarding
his romance with mj it's complicated
spider-man fans everywhere first started
rooting for these kooky kids back in
2002 and spent three films watching
there will they or won't they romance
play out on screen after all of that
teenage angst followed by an implied
happy ending this one liner comes across
as a slap in the face look we get it
adult life is difficult enough when
you're not a web-slinging superhero plus
the third film showed how tricky it is
dating someone with a double identity
however no way home doesn't really have
the right to retcon one of the most
iconic couples in superhero history
i can't survive without you
additionally the throwaway line doesn't
add anything to the story and only
confuses audiences we also hear peter
talk about mj saying we made it work not
only is the past tense of that sentiment
confusing it makes it unclear whether
peter and mj are still going the
distance basically the moment cast a
dark cloud over an otherwise epic cameo
happy and aunt may aren't exactly a
couple written in the stars and happy is
not a character who's always taken
seriously but he still deserves to be
treated as more than a vehicle for
comedy relief it's pretty clear that
happy is a tad more invested in his
non-relationship with may than she is
but no way home takes it to a whole
other level peter comes home after his
identity as spider-man is outed to have
another awkward family sit down happy
amazed breakup tries to ease attention
of peter's situation but in hindsight
it's not very funny happy certainly
needs to accept that they're not in the
same page romantically
mae could break things off with happy a
bit more tactfully may's death is one of
the most devastating scenes in tom
holland's trilogy but her death also
means that her savage breakup with happy
is the last memory he has of her he
never really gets the closure he
deserves and sure that's life but it's
still a pretty sad place to leave happy
at the end of this movie
when it comes to the villains and no way
home the majority are given ample space
to explore their psyches and work
through some of their trauma however the
attention is largely skewed towards sam
raimi's set of villains whereas green
goblin and dark arc truly work to become
better people we miss out on those
nuances with the lizard and electro from
the amazing spider-man series granted
both the amazing spider-man villains are
developed far more in their original
films than raymie's set but fans would
still like to see more from them in no
way home the lizard and electro are
opposed to tom holland's pizza helping
them but they have no choice in the end
all three peters force them into a cure
which isn't a great message when helping
people is the tagline then with little
build up everyone is happy to be back to
normal the movie does what it can with
its time but it would be nice to see a
bit more depth from the amazing
spider-man crew and even raymie sandman
we get one great moment with elektro
when he remarks his surprise that
spider-man isn't black but hopes that
there is a universe where he is of
course spidey fans know that this is a
shout out to miles morales who recently
appeared in spider-man into the
spider-verse
okay we get it tony sark was responsible
for some pretty incredible technological
advances during his time at stark
industries of course that unbridled
power would attract villains however
some things are sacred like tony's arc
reactor that's because it's a
miniaturized dark reactor
it makes sense that mcu creators want to
keep iron man's legacy alive in new
projects but there are other ways to
accomplish that without insulting his
memory when electro uses tony's arc
reactor it's hard not to take the
dastardly use of iron man's most iconic
piece of tech personally his arc reactor
is what kept the mcu's first superhero
alive and post-mortem it would be nice
if he could retire that particular piece
of superhero history rather than
corrupting and distorting its purpose so
long after tony's death iron man's
memory deserves more than being a tool
for villains to take advantage of let
the man rest in peace
doctor strange may be a pro at chaotic
spell work with unintended consequences
burt has botched jobs and no way home
takes the cake sure we need a catalyst
for the multiverse villains to appear in
this world but even for strange this is
a lot when peter continually tries to
intervene drawing stranger's spell it
becomes horribly unstable and blows up
in both of their faces but at the end of
the day strange is an adult with more
than enough experience to know better
than to let peter meddle with his spells
he caters to peter's whims multiple
times until peter himself changes the
incantation but it should never get that
far strange blames peter for the bungled
spell work but look who his role model
is
we started getting some visitors
even worse more than a few plot holes
emerge regarding strange's clumsy magic
wielding when all is said and done yet
the worst of it comes at the end of the
film when peter asked strange to do a
spell to make everyone forget that he's
spider-man even michelle and ned however
it doesn't just make them forget
spidey's identity they don't remember
peter at all even students he's gone to
school with for years who knew peter
before his spidey identity forgot him
all in all it's frustrating to end the
trilogy with more questions than answers
with a completely trusting partnership
tom holland's peter has cultivated in
his own mj it's disheartening when he
takes away her autonomy over their
relationship michelle knows the risks of
being spider-man's girlfriend and she's
more than capable of holding her own but
once everyone's memory of peter goes
away with stranger spell he decides that
she should live her life without him
peter made a promise to michelle before
the spell that he would find her and
tell her everything that happened so
they could work on rebuilding their
relationship instead he pockets his
speech and walks away taking her choice
away from her which is undeniably
heartbreaking and cruel
taking three betas from spider-man
universes hailing from different decades
could have ended in disaster still
writers eric summers and chris mckenna
seamlessly pull it off alongside
director john watts and of course the
web-slinging actors themselves without
missing a beat toby maguire and andrew
garfield dusted off their cobwebs and
delivered heartfelt performances with
their usual dash of humor and one-liners
fans can even argue that their
respective cameos are even better than
their original roles these cameos could
have been shallow and fleeting but
instead they each have meaningful
character arcs in their quest to help
the next generation spider-man and that
credit goes to everyone who worked on
the project it would have been such a
letdown to see the ogs come back for a
frivolous minute or two but we get to
know this older iteration of our heroes
and it's a gift
toby maguire's peter parker spends a
good part of the franchise struggling
with his thirst for vengeance between
his quest to find and kill uncle ben's
killer to being somewhat responsible for
norman osborn's death quite a few people
have died at the hands of our friendly
neighbourhood spider-man turns out it
was really some man who shot uncle ben
but whatever spider revenge
in no way home we see some holland
spider-man grapple with a similar
mission to even the score after green
goblin kills aunt may however maguire's
beater can't stand the idea of watching
another peter go down this dark path and
stops him from becoming a cold-blooded
killer the moment our 2002 peter parker
convinces peter to spare norman he hands
a baton to holland allowing a new
generation to take it from here watching
maguire's peter get some closure and
peace through helping a younger version
of himself is a beautiful moment that
mends some of his old scars one of the
biggest flaws superhero films fall into
even in modern times is making its women
helpless damsels who need saving every 5
minutes however in no way home michelle
and peter save each other on countless
occasions in an equal partnership the
update on the usual trope is a
refreshing signal that times are
changing and so must our superheroes
everyone needs help sometimes and it's
nice to see peter accept assistance from
someone he loves instead of pushing it
away if you're going to have a woman by
your side when you're fighting crimes
and taking names michelle jones is the
best out there and she's not afraid to
call peter out when he needs it either
what are you hiding
peter
when you grow up with the avengers it's
easy to get into a mentality that every
problem needs solving via magic or a
heavy duty piece of stark industries
tech however the mcu's peter parker is
still a teenager with typical human
issues like not getting into college
sure the reason he doesn't get into mit
is rooted in the fact that he spent the
last years of his life running around a
spider-man still before trying to
magically whammy the world with an
amnesia spell peter really should have
contacted the school to explain his
position once dr strange calls him out
on a serious lack of critical thinking
peter does find someone at mit he
complete his case to using his typical
charm he wins her over
dark arc is one of spider-man's most
fleshed out foes when it comes to the
og's spider-man trilogy his journey has
three parts dog's initial introduction
his villainous descent and ultimately
reclaiming his kind-hearted nature and
defeating himself no way home expands on
his already developed dark and makes it
even better by bringing fans more of ox
humanity no way home allows him to truly
become the hero and save his fellow
villains and the process many of
spider-man's villains deserve much more
space to explore their humanity and
villainhood than the original films
allowed this is most definitely true of
the first film's green goblin even
before norman turns into the goblin he
isn't winning any father of the year
awards the villain barely grapples with
his humanity even when he's fighting off
his evil alter ego and it's hard to root
for the guy when he has so little
substance no way home corrects that by
giving norman proper space to make
better choices and access his humanity
both villains get concrete storylines
that correct some of their
superficiality in the og's
gwen stacy's death in the amazing
spider-man 2 is one of the most gripping
and heartbreaking scenes in any of the
spidey films released before no way home
many fans don't give garfield the credit
to spider-man deserves but he nails this
moment and its 2.0 counterpart and no
way home when michelle falls off the
statue of liberty in an identical way to
gwen it's not her own pizza who saves
her but garfield's setting aside his own
trauma he leaps into action and catches
michelle to spare this universe as peter
from going through the same eternal
grief and guilt he did no way home gives
garfield's peter the nuanced and deep
ending he's always deserved it's clear
that peter hasn't moved on from what
happened to gwen and saving michelle
gives him the closure he needs to move
on with his life and start living it
fully again fans of andrew garfield's
take on spider-man couldn't be more
grateful check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about spider-man no way home are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]